Peggy 18
look behind you at June after June of
drifting half-forgotten Terrace you flee
them these past phantoms and the madness
that crawls inside Griffi can help you
venture down to where you can't go
yourself and lay bare your true promise
you have grown into a violent thing the
man of solitude drifting across these
sands fearing those who make you feel
human you know nothing of me I know what
you seek and I know where you can find
it
there's something brewing out there more
boys from gas town are tightening the
noose fierce lake
people get in my way people can show you
the lights help you survive people can
bring you the sauce you so desperately
desire war boys have been cited prep and
most likely for an assault on our
beloved shield
you wish to know more about yourself
more about the man you become but this
is a very different world my friend you
tell me son w-what tell me why I
shouldn't land a slug right between your
eyes
if you hope to survive navigate the
flood escape the past there forever
haunts you then open your eyes in the
darkest hour the believers standing
above the sacred sand will behold the
true light I'm looking hard there's
nothing
look again
it's right there in front of you